[Musique]
dans cette petite taverne de baie saint
paul se brasse une bière qui voudraient
atteindre tout un sommet celui d'être
servis au chef du g7 une bière qui est
plus longue à faire que d'autres perdent
par son taux d'alcool et la fermentation
froide mais il faut être un peu plus
patient qu'avec le reste de notre
production
et le résultat est une belle longueur
démocratique apolitique
une élaboration dont lui seul a le
secret et son objectif est très
diplomatique nous ce qu'on veut c'est
que toute l'ailé les grands conflits et
puis toutes les petites chicanes de ce
monde qu'elle soit grosse ou petite ces
chicanes l'appui se régler autour d'une
bonne bière
si la bière g7 veut se rendre au sommet
elle devra passer de nombreuses
barrières de sécurité parlez-en aux
propriétaires de cette maison qui se
trouve dans la zone actuellement la plus
sécurisée du canada et ce n'est pas de
la petite bière
la maison est même pas beau et je
rendrai qu'on est dans un autre univers
il a beau être en bas de l'escalier qui
mène directement au lieu du sommet du g7
il n'aura pas de passe-droit pour aller
voir une certaine invités à arrêter
madame preuve pourquoi soit avocat elle
la trouve très jolie
il ya pas de honte à se dire cela
pas de lait l'ania non plus dans la
bière g7 mais un peu de donald puisque
le brasseur nicolas marrant concocte sa
bière à base de cet ingrédient 17 pays
du groupe de l'orge du canada de
l'avoine du royaume uni de leurs lots de
blé italien ainsi que du houblon
américains français et japonais
on a pour finir la levure allemande de
l'institut de bayonne stefan qui est une
très belle souche de levure à la guerre
de très belles génétique pour faire
monter à froid l'ensemble de ces
ingrédients
d'autres se nomme merkel qui fait
fermenter le tout via sa politique c'est
de cette usine que la bière une fois
embouteillée devrait partir en direction
de la malbaie avec comme objectif de se
rapprocher le plus possible des chefs
d'état
[Musique]
une proximité de l'endroit convoité qui
n'est pas sans contrainte pour certains
comme bien des auberges l'hôtel voisin
du manoir richelieu a été réquisitionné
par les autorités pour loger des invités
confidentiel bonnes affaires pierre
marchand n'est pas trop sur la limite de
la zone et d'ici au milieu de la rue
alors les jeunes champions côté peuvent
pas venir ici mais on ne sait pas les
gens qui sont actuellement de ce côté
ici s'il vaut mieux jouer nous c'est un
peu comme si les résidents étaient un
peu pris prisonniers de leur propre vie
c'est ça devient compliqué de circuler
c'est normal des événements comme fort
non loin de là dans la forteresse du
manoir richelieu on est fébrile on
s'entend que un événement de cette
envergure là ils se présentent peut-être
une fois dans une vie dans l'atelier
quand on est chanceux fait que nos très
très très très flatté fier et content
les clôtures les mesures de sécurité les
contraintes tout cela est temporaire
mais que va-t-il vraiment rester de ce
sommet il faut noter que dans charlevoix
la clientèle être à peu près à 90% année
sur année des québécois qui viennent
nous visiter
donc nous on a tout on aspire à être
connues en dehors de l'ue du québec en
dehors du canada et c'est une
opportunité de rêve ont jamais on
n'aurait pu se payer une telle pub car
charlevoix sera sous les feux de la
rampe du monde entier pendant quelques
jours mais l'impact est encore difficile
à chiffrer
presqu'un tangible
y aura t'il quelque chose de permanent
de concret après le sommet oui ces
petites étiquettes rouges qui pullulent
dans la région symbole de la connexion
internet haute vitesse par fibre optique
installé grâce au sommet il ya des
investissements majeurs en
télécommunications donc ça c'est bon
pour tous c'est bon pour les entreprises
c'est bon pour les citoyens c'est bon
pour la vitalité économique du
territoire
donc un excellent signal cellulaire un
internet à la vitesse de l'éclair
de quoi célébrer avec une bière qui ne
sera pas non plus éphémère enfin presque
est-ce que là j'essaie va survivre au g7
s'est pas dans les plats c'est ce cas-ci
là j'essaie de faire un super succès
c'est sûr que si l'ag site devient un
must incontournable
on verra ce qu'ils ont peut pas soir la
garde et la faire évoluer ou bon on est
fermé à rien en attendant le g77
cervoise houblonnée est déjà rendu au
manoir une bière tout en équilibre sur
le fil du consensus sans trop d'amertume
comme un bon sommeil